la pêche s'arrête mardi à 13h alors
c'est pour l'information à tous les
professionnels et aussi aux amateurs à
partir de mardi c'est fini alors
pourquoi on arrête c'est à cause des
volontés du sur le terrain il ya pas mal
de hossam les sources n est pas de
qualité n'est pas mature c'est dû à la
forte pluviométrie de ces derniers jours
donc on peut faire un espèce de principe
de précaution on a eu des remontées
depuis vendredi on voulait arrêter de
plus vendredi mais on s'est dit bon pour
le délai administratif pour monsieur le
préfet puis je prenne un arrêté ça
nécessitait un peu plus de temps donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a pris on lui a fait
d'abord celle par voie de courrier on a
fait le nécessaire en amont pour voir
arrêté mardi à 13h alors on va faire une
prospection dans vingt jours pour voir
l'état de la ressource et puis pouvoir
si le lot sein de qualité c'est les
gonades sont corrects et si toutefois
tout est au beau fixe on va ouvrir comme
pour la paix elle prévue en décembre
mais cela nécessite une une prospection
en avons demandé à radier mais la
préfecture de faire les contrôles à
partir de mercredi jeudi et les
sanctions derrière il faudrait des
sanctions pour tous ceux qui l'ont pas
écouté ce que les braconniers nous font
énormément de mal on a vu il ya des
zones où on avait prospecté ya un mois
au pendant qu'on prospectait on voit la
présence de braconniers qui était avant
on pouvait dire cdti jeunes allende à
monsieur lambda on a même vu les marins
pêcheurs aussi braconniers donc j'ai
envie aux collègues d'être quand même un
sérieux à ce niveau là